[Música]
ae
a vila mais famosa vamos receber o
terreno negativo com os esmaltes brasil
e do mundo em busca da unidade
o chamado do senhor todos os anos no
carnaval quando essa sirenes tocam esses
fogos estouraram quando a água começa a
introdução no sambódromo do anhembi em
são paulo
cerca de 4 mil pessoas se emocionam se
abraçam e choram porque chegou o momento
de colocar na avenida e mostrar para o
mundo inteiro através da televisão o
trabalho de oito meses são oito meses
ardoz de trabalho tá certo pra gente
conseguir ter uma hora só de festa
é isso que conversar com você que hoje
eu soube há 20 anos dirigente da escola
de samba e se tem gente inútil nessa
vida de um bando de desocupados é o
pessoal do carnaval
o carnaval não serve pra absolutamente
nada isso é sensacional vivos inúteis o
mundo é doce lutz
o mundo é dos desocupados porque meninos
a gente tem uma relação muito complicada
porque uma relação utilitarista com as
coisas a gente pra que serve o que
ganhar com isso agora muito mais rápido
e eu estou hoje me defender essa ideia a
utilidade do inútil o mundo o ardi é dos
inúteis
a gente vai vencer essa vida você vai
ver os milhares serão ainda exaltados de
lutas também serão exaltados e no
carnaval é muita gente lute
nossa escola tem é uma das mais antigas
são paulo ano que vem 2020
a gente faz 65 anos né mais de meio
século de história e até hoje a gente
não ganhou nenhum título do grupo
especial de são paulo como continuar
motivado depois de 65 anos sucessivos de
fracasso
a pergunta é essa você conseguiria ficar
65 anos motivados para atingir uma meta
o que tem nessa escola de samba que tem
no carnaval que tem na cultura popular
na arte que faz a gente conseguir ficar
motivado por tanto tempo mesmo
fracassado
mesmo derrotado meninos pessoal é a
paixão é a paixão que faz a gente
acreditar
o senso de comunidade tem alguma coisa
no carnaval na cultura que só a arte
traz que faz a gente acreditar que é
possível morder a vida mesmo quando o
resultado não é o que a gente quer
hoje essa relação utilitarista que a
gente está vivendo eu conheço muito bem
e há 20 anos na bolsa de valores até
hoje ouço vozes ouço vozes o seu voto no
caso da bolsa de valores na bolsa de
valores minha vida na planilha metas
atingir superávit
resultados e eu posso ser bem sincero
isso não completava a minha vida e você
sabe disso né
a gente hoje têm usado essa dívida é o
utilitarismo contaminou inclusive as
relações humanas
nós usamos temos bancários tá certo para
falar das relações humanas e entrou
pessoais que eu ganho ficando com você o
que o lucro continua nessa relação que
vantagem eu levo
se eu ficar por aqui ganhar vantagem
lucrará o carnaval me ensinou a gente eu
perdi o que eu já pedi dinheiro minha
família me odeia porque o tempo inteiro
né eu ter enviado e divida por uma coisa
que nunca dá certo
o início é ser financeiros e contábil
ness e uma relação só peculiar com as
coisas isso não faz a gente se uma
pessoa feliz com certeza isso não dá uma
sensação uma sociedade de vida
existe um grande escritor japonês
chamado cáculo okazuka cura em que diz o
seguinte ele escreveu um livro sobre a
cerimônia do chá e ele disse que um dia
um homem olhou para flores e achou
bonito e 15 então presente a a sua
mulher amada e fez uma guirlanda de
flores
ele diz que esse é um momento
fundamental na história da humanidade
o primeiro homem que colocou uma
guirlanda de flores no pescoço da sua
amada separou os homens dos animais
os homens da besta nós somos a única
espécie que é capaz de ter a fruição o
deleite da beleza saber ver na beleza
delicadeza das coisas e coisas que não
são úteis alguma funcionalidade isso é
fundamental para separar os homens dos
animais porque tem gente que ainda não
chegou nessa qualidade humana é porque
falta que só têm uma relação a gente não
quer só comida a gente quer comida
diversão e arte
você vai fazer um favor pra você mesmo
como eu aprendi depois da escola depois
do da oposto de valores chegando no
carnaval
você vai enfiar na sua vida não precisa
ser pode ser fotografia literatura vai
dançar tocar violão que o programa um
ser humano melhor
a arte faz a gente ser um ser humano
muito melhor só que todos nós somos
artistas mas pouco a pouco vão matando
nosso espírito artístico
parece que a vida né pagar boletos
infelizmente necessário é comprar uma
blusinha todo mundo gosta
mais que isso vida a meta de vida de uma
pessoa ea gente não consegue tocar uma
vida muito tempo animado e motivado
só assim seja
só quando era pequenininha lá no
maternal chegou a época da páscoa
o professor de um coelhinho para você
tentar saber a jesus por que você pegou
uns dias de ser azul escuro e pintou
todo com ele não respeitou nem uma linha
no limite todo errado é todo equivocado
mas as professoras é aquela fase da
escola são uma espécie de coaching e
infantil parabéns continue assim né você
me orgulha muito
sua mãe pegou então lima colocou na
porta da geladeira você achou que você
era um novo o sucesso do bairro chegou a
primeira série do primário chegou a
páscoa novamente e que deram novamente o
coelhinho pra você pintar você falar deu
certo lá atrás
vou fazer de novo que aconteceu agora
você já respeito às linhas de respeitar
contornos mas pegou os dias cenas no
escuro e pintou o coelhinho professora
começa a desenvolver um trabalho escolar
setor empolgado que você imagina
parabéns ao sensacional época a tia
falou lá atrás que era sensacional né
ela começa a devolver pra você
o coelhinho e um seu último da pilha
você tornou se hoje o seu elogio à
mostra na sala pessoal exige coelhinhas
no escuro não então porque é que você
tem todas você nunca mais pintar nada na
sua vida naquele dia matar o seu pintor
inimigo é muito pequenininho é a gente é
sempre é o pai há sítio da família das
festinhas dança partidas pode ser adiada
neco aninhos e dança com dois amigos e
dança com três anos e dança com quatro
meses e dança com cinco dias de dança
com seis anos lá e botar esse moleque no
judô
naquele dia matar o seu dançarino e mata
o nosso dançarino mata o nosso cantor
mata o nosso pintor
então vamos fazer um esforço pessoal
está certo de integrar a arte da nossa
vida
a minha relação com a escola de samba -
varia muito engraçada eu frequento
carnaval 40 anos desde a adolescência eu
moro na vila maria mas um colega eu
morava e essa escola que é muito antiga
só pra morrer porque faltam 30 dias do
carnaval e ainda não tinha feito nada
o desfile e se você não desfilam ano
você é punido pela prefeitura ficar
cinco anos sem receber verba resultado a
escola e acabar eu achei muito né um
pecado um patrimônio cultural da cidade
tão antigo terminar assim
agora fazer qualquer coisa e ver
exatamente nós fizemos qualquer coisa e
brigamos os ferros do carro alegórico
fizemos a fantasia lá de qualquer jeito
e desfilamos e ficamos em terceiro lugar
porém um
tá fácil esse negócio aí e aí a gente
começou a fazer um trabalho mais
proativo mais determinado e aí a escola
me honrou com esse orgulho que eu tenho
é uma honra e eu fui presidente da
escola de samba durante quatro anos em
quatro anos os campeões três vezes
seguidas e subimos três vezes grupo
direto tá certo mas aonde serviço foi
meu talento é meu mérito não e porque eu
descobri uma potencialidade naquela
comunidade
uma comunidade que conseguia ter brilho
no olho mesmo tendo aquela sede social
deixa lá em cima
aquela nossa sede social era um salão de
20 metros quadrados quer uma espécie de
coringa no bairro ali acontecia as
reuniões de escola de samba
os velórios do bairro cultos evangélicos
também há reuniões da sessão de barro
tudo acontecia neste neste salão
pequenininho e uma escola que com isso
conseguir fazer tudo aquilo foi a tem
potencialidade aqui e foi isso que eu
descobrir que consegui potencializar
naquela escola
a gente então passou por muitos
perrengues vocês não têm noção do que é
o dia a dia de uma escola de samba
no primeiro ano do presidente por um
erro de comunicação nós somos todos lá
preparado para entrar no anhembi os
carros bonitos muito lindos não tinha
nenhum empurrador de carro alegórico não
chegaram nem a última de merendeiro que
os carros não entrou a fundar a escola
no primeiro ano do carnaval
eu me coloco na minha presidência
começou a botar gente botar botar gente
até de outras escolas e nós empurramos
os quatro carros e o que se percebe que
não tenho um físico de halterofilista tá
certo me carregando quatro carros
alegóricos e cada um pesa pelo menos
meia tonelada
eu empurrava o primeiro quando saía da
avenida especial voltada à epal seguro e
por fim os quatro carros alegóricos se
uma suposta ausência de força física é
um empreendimento né pode preparar para
fazer uma ação que possibilitasse fazer
uma ação preconceitos nem fazem isso né
no ano o seguinte outro perrengue um
ônibus com os baianos não chegava não
chegava não chegava a um número mínimo
de baianas para entrar na avenida e aí
eu vi homens com suas limitações nem com
suas preconceitos com sua visão de mundo
se oferecendo para se vestir de baiana
para entrar na avenida a escola perder
pontos
de tão grande que a paixão pela unidos
de vila maria não foi necessário ainda
bem porque seria um desrespeito com os
baianos o ônibus chegou é aceitar
ocorrendo atrasados avenida chegaram mas
veja eu sou capaz de passar por cima de
um preconceito mas eu achava que está
nos grupos de baixo mas
quando chegar no grupo especial dinheiro
transmissão pela televisão tudo vai dar
certo a gente vai ter sucesso
quem dera em 2018 agora uma tragédia
foi um carnaval mais sobre o desfile
durou uma hora e dez desfiles chorei de
uma hora e 10 sem parar
assim que a nossa porta bandeira entrou
na avenida uma roupa dessa coisa pelo
menos 15 mil reais para que ela colocou
dois três passos caiu a saia dela no
meio da avenida cento e poucos países
vendo pela televisão tá certo ea gente
tem que trocar o pneu do carro com o
carro andando
era uma cena dantesca cada um que
colocava a mão caiu um pedaço da roupa
dela e ela ficou de bermuda e essa era
uma ofensa é porque a porta-bandeira
praticamente na primeira dama da escola
com um símbolo maior da escola foi muito
bonito gesto é necessário levar um com
pedaço da sua fantasia e cobriu a perna
dela ela poder desfilar seja a gente tem
que ser muito rápido o raciocínio e só a
arte faz isso
a arte a cultura elas essa nosso recorde
cerebral uma área que só ela é capaz de
dar criatividade a trabalhar com o
inusitado soluções rápidas por isso que
faculdade de medicina de ponta tem
colocado em seu currículo história da
arte e as ciências humanas
a faculdade de medicina da pensilvânia
no estado americano da filadélfia a
colocou no seu currículo obrigatório
medicina visita a exposições de artes
porque se percebeu que isso aumentou o
centro de observação a empatia tá certo
a capacidade crítica mas não é uma coisa
bonita assim do ponto de vista abstrato
resultados práticos melhorou com
substancialmente a qualidade da análise
de imagens clínicas de exames de retina
por exemplo olha que a arte é capaz de
fazer
ela é capaz de se fazer a gente crescer
né a gente colocou então a nossa escola
além da parte artística cidadania em
2002 a gente era profético e a gente já
sabia que a palavra do século 21 seria
intolerância o nosso tema do carnaval
foi intolerância em 2002
trouxemos um professor da usp de 15 de
palestras para a comunidade gente muito
humilde
a nossa escola hoje a identidade de
gênero é respeitada nos banheiros uma
escola que era super preconceituosa que
a comunidade lgbt
hoje o banheiro é aprender de gênero foi
na nossa escola que aconteceu o primeiro
agente cedeu o espaço quando o seu
primeiro concurso da corte oficial gay
do carnaval de são paulo
nós temos uma uma integrante
trans e ela conseguiu hoje é obrigatório
aceitar o nome social mas antigamente
não e ela conseguiu na justiça o nome
dela social porque no deferimento da
juíza ela alegou que como a carteirinha
dela na escola de samba há muitos anos
ela era chamada de andréia então é
porque a sociedade reconhecer com mulher
pra nós é um orgulho e uma honra saber
disso
isso é muito bonito a gente trabalha na
escola de samba com argila dos sonhos
quadrilha da esperança e meninos sem
esperança e sem sonhos
a gente vira a fera a gente volta esse
animal pode ver que todos os times que
passou no futuro da distopia as pessoas
são organizadas por quem quer só comer
quem conseguir água e só isso a gente
vira uma fera fernando pessoa tem um
plano que ele fala que sem loucura sem a
beleza sem arte que somos nós mais do
que uma besta dia um cadáver adiado que
procria se eu não tiver sonho eu sou uma
besta dia uma vaca um gado como grama
faz filhote programa faz filhote que o
crime fosse lote a subir mais que uma
besta sá dia um cadáver adiado que
procria então a gente conseguiu fazer
muito mais pela escola de samba para
aqueles integrantes grande pessoa a não
ficar só fazendo não é de de carnaval a
gente pode muito mais
a verdadeira grandeza começar onde você
está usar o que você tem e fazer o que
você pode esse interesse americano
primeiro negro que ganhou e blindou que
é uma inspiração para nós
arthur ashe que a gente fez a gente pode
mais pode trazer esperança para a
comunidade como a gente fez isso né a
gente tem um projeto social chamado um
caso de amor cujo lema é muito além do
carnaval
em 18 anos de avenida e de vida desse
projeto a gente já atendeu mais de 180
mil pessoas na área da saúde
nós temos médicos fisioterapeutas os
dentistas equoterapia temos alguns
cavalos que fazer terapia com as
crianças da comunidade
tem gente que vai ao sus e depois
recomendado para a nossa escola que o
atendimento é mais rápido
é tudo gratuito temos recursos de
esporte cursos profissionalizantes a
gente pode muito mais do que
simplesmente né a oferecer um carnaval
pra aquela comunidade mas não é só a
vila maria né
eu tenho muito orgulho da minha escola
mas também o carnaval como um todo é a
mangueira tem o título mangueira do
futuro em jundiaí a projetos sociais e
de escolas de samba existe um projeto
chamado carnaval do bem solidário né as
duas cesta básica
tem festa de dia das crianças a casa
fizemos como de casamento comunitário
nossa escola está certo é bonito é nossa
quando ela voltou a ter né aquela
primeira origem que ela tinha ela
continua até hoje né sendo uma escola
que recebe de tudo a gente conseguiu
ainda existem cultos evangélicos já
ocorreu em nossa escola de samba
encontros espíritas bingos tá certo
festa de casamento de que não pode
alugar o salão festa de aniversário tudo
acontece na comunidade são poucos os
dias da semana e do ano que a escola
fica fechada ela fica 24 horas aberta
para todo mundo
esperança a gente trouxe à nossa
comunidade esperança nisso a gente eu
aprendi isso mais uma exposição que a
escola de samba me deu saber que eu sou
uma pessoa histórica eu me mantenha
motivado mesmo sem ganhar o carnaval é
nada o carnaval porque eu lembro da
história da vila maria à olho naquele
ano foi 10.2 nós fosse por 0.1 aí vem o
velhinho da velha guarda no carnaval de
74 se tornar uma pessoa histórica e traz
esperança hoje muitas pessoas são sempre
tão sem esperança nessa vida porque são
a históricos não querem saber do passado
que interessa à revolução né da
revolução desde a revolta de canudos a
guerra dos cem anos não querem saber do
futuro e ficar preso só o presente não
traz alento traz esperança se olhar só
aqui a gente fica muito triste
feminicídio misoginia assédio moral e
sexual das mulheres se eu me inspiro no
rio
esperançoso da história eu vejo o quanto
as mulheres avançaram enquanto os
direitos quanto as mulheres ocuparam
cargos importantes da república
brasileira
você olha só aqui e dá desalento me dá
muita tristeza o país que mais mata
transexuais no mundo o brasil mas hoje
nós já temos deputados às assembléias
legislativas que são transexuais
quando me insiro no rio esperançoso da
história eu fico mais feliz consigo
tocar a vida
dante alighieri coloca lá na divina
comédia que o inferno você vai entrar no
inferno tem um portal e até escrito né
ao entrar aqui deixa aqui a sua
esperança e essa é a melhor definição
que pode existir de inferno inferno é
uma vida sem esperança missão sem amor a
gente vinha numa boa mudar o trabalho
agora sem esperança a gente não vive por
isso a esperança é a última que morre
sem esperança a gente não vive a
esperança é a coisa mais importante que
tem está certo ea gente tem esperança
inclusive de vencer preconceitos
externos
vencemos se nós vencermos preconceitos
internos de alguns integrantes da
comunidade lgbt
nós vencemos também preconceitos
externos nós somos a primeira escola de
samba que foi apoiado pela igreja
católica em 2017 o nosso desfile foi os
300 anos da aparição da padroeira do
brasil ea igreja católica apoio nosso
desfile colocou algumas regras que nós
respeitamos e hoje o samba enredo que
nós cantamos na avenida faz parte do
cenário da igreja católica em aparecida
do norte e canta um samba enredo da
unidos de vila maria mas conseguiu
vencer o preconceito externo
eu volto a insistir na minha linha para
mim o encontro com vocês aqui
compartilhar com vocês
essa idéia a mais do que boletos a mais
do que metas planilhas para se vencer
quando vou escolher uma profissão para
duas escolhas ou eu vou escolher passar
fome ou passar tédio quem escolher
passar ted para não passar fome vai
morrer de tédio e de fome porque vai
chegar a hora que não agüenta mais
aquele emprego quem escolher passar fome
mas quer seguir sua paixão nunca vai
passar fome
já dizia o nosso tenista arte oeste
se a riqueza só sei que zeca é o segredo
da felicidade os ricos deveriam estar
dançando nas ruas mas quem das ruas são
as crianças pobres na vila maria a gente
vê isso nossas crianças têm alegria
dessas crianças vão ser históricos
nossas crianças são esperançosos porque
a gente sempre sabe disso
vai chegar o nosso dia o nosso momento
coração vai disparar
ninguém vai me segurar na hora que a
vila maria passar
sonhei com esse dia e o sonho se tornou
real eu faço a profecia vila maria
campeã do carnaval vai chegar a gente
atrai todos os anos porque um dia vai
chegar o nosso tempo pode não ser agora
pode ser que vem mas vai chegar e quando
chegar vai ser lindo ver a cultura viva
a arte viva a a a cultura popular e
sobretudo vivos inúteis
obrigado
[Aplausos]